[Music]
what's up everyone I'm Alicia Malone
this is Fandango indie movie Guide and
let's kick things off with a worthy
farewell to a great actor who has
recently passed away Harry Dean Stanton
in lucky realism is the practice of
accepting a situation as it is what
you're saying is what you see is what
you get what you see lucky is directed
by John Carroll Lynch who is not the
Zodiac killer he is an actor turned
director and this is a beautiful love
letter to the career and life of Harry
Dean Stanton it serves as the perfect
way to wrap up such a brilliant
heartfelt career filled with amazing
performances here he plays an aging
atheist who is searching for his own
spiritual journey his own meaning of
life wandering through the desert yes
it's quite reminiscent of Paris Texas
it's got a great little co-starring
performance by director David Lynch who
was a really close friend of Harry Dean
Stanton but to have a wonderful
conversation about turtles I know the
truth and the truth matters and you have
to face that and accept it there are
some things in this universe ladies and
gentlemen that are bigger than all of us
and our TARDIS is one of them Harry Dane
once again puts in a beautiful
performance this was one of my favorite
films at the South by Southwest Film
Festival earlier this year and though it
is very very sad timing that Harry Dean
didn't live to see the release of this
film out to theaters it really is a nice
way to pay your respects so this weekend
say farewell to Harry Dean Stanton by
going and watching lucky it's beautiful
do this to my eyes
how about you just suck it
[Music]
something completely different also out
in limited theaters and on video and
demand is literally right before Aaron
this is a romantic comedy starring Cobie
Smulders and Justin long it's directed
by Ryan Eggold who is himself an actor
turned director it's got a fairly
familiar premise there's a guy played by
Justin Long who used to date a girl
played by Cobie Smulders just before she
started to date this guy Aaron who she's
getting married to
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I'd like to be there really mm-hmm
it's reminiscent of something like the
Graduate and it does fall into the very
familiar beats of a romantic comedy but
I really like all the cast involved and
you know there's quite a big part of me
that just enjoys an escapist romantic
comedy where you can switch off your
brain and just go along for the ride
[Music]
sorry if that sounds like your jam you
can see literally right before Aaron in
select theaters or in the comfort of
your own home from this weekend speak
now or forever hold your peace
speaking of watching things at home on
Fandango now you can see the beguiled
which is still one of my favorite films
of this year
directed by Sofia Coppola it's a remake
of a 1970s film and also based on a book
is he dad no get him inside this is a
sexy dark gothic Srila set during the
civil war in the south where a soldier
from the north played by Colin Farrell
stumbles into an all-girls boarding
school he is hurt they look after him
and then things start to get a little
bit twisted it's got a great performance
by head of the household nicole kidman
who is killing it this year both in the
theaters and on television as well as
Kirsten Dunst and Elle Fanning it seems
the enemy it's not what we believe I
hope you like apple pie is that my
recipe it is
I love the mood of the piece that kind
of feels like Virgin Suicides
you can see the beguiled on Fandango now
right now
so let's go through my recommendations
for this week in theatres say goodbye to
the wonderful Harry Dean Stanton in
lucky or just have a romantic good time
with literally right before Erin at home
you can stay in and watch Sophia Coppola
is gothic thriller the beguiled but what
say you do any of those take your fancy
what has been one of your favorite films
of this year in the eyes I mean I'm
elation Malone you can also keep in
contact with me on Twitter at my leisure
Malone and I'll see you soon
[Music]